genius brain listeners this podcast is
brought to you by Mint mobile from
billion dooll ad budgets and Arena
naming rights to tens of thousands of
retail locations big Wireless providers
spend big to appear like they're your
only options all plans come with
unlimited talking text high-speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5G
Network and with those savings my
friends I'm I'll buy myself a meal maybe
a massage here and there times be tough
lately so get on Mt mobile and don't
waste your money on other Wireless
providers that just be upcharging you up
the wazo to get your new Wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month and get the
plan shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com genius5 that's
mintmobile.com genius5 cut your wireless
build of 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com
genius5 genius brain farts this podcast
is brought to you by fume have you ever
tried to go cold turkey on a bad habit
that's no good well try out fume fume
looks at the problem of bad habits in a
different way fume is an Innovative
award-winning flavored air device that
do just that I had this like T1 this
herbal T1 amazing I enjoyed it a lot was
puffing that away and guess what did it
without any guilt stopping is something
we all put off because it's hard but
switching to fume is easy and enjoyable
and even fun fume has served over
150,000 customers and a thousands of
success stories and there's no reason
that can't be you join fum in
accelerating human breaker from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today head to tri.com and
use code genus to save 10% off when you
get the journey pack today that's
tri.com and use code genius to save an
additional 10% off your order today my
lovely genius brain fart this podcast is
brought to you by mood mood my friends
is known for their federally legal THC
but now they're adding their most potent
product yet to the lineup introducing
hemp based thca flow the future of legal
THC tried along with all of mood's other
amazing offerings like delta8 flower
gummies Vape cartridges and a whole
bunch more and for a limited time mood
is giving our listeners a free gram of
thca flour and 20% off your first order
just visit hello.com and use our code
genius it's my little night cap that I
use to help me get some restful sleep
and I love it great little night cap my
friends try mood's new thca flour today
and for 20% off your first order and a
free gram of thca flour go to hello.com
and use promo code genius that's hell
o.com promo code genius for 20% off your
order at a free gram of thca flour
today she reaches in her vagina pulls
out a bird and we're like the out this
bird she puts in it Bird's not fluster
bird chill it's chilling like it's B
there many times this what this mother
got a black the audio you're good I'm
good sitting like this cuz I got real
comfortable you get real Comfort
sometimes my balls slip out here come
on like a little Roman coin purse that's
hilarious I got to chill out with the
short short that's [__] hilarious you
get older your balls get a little looser
come on man they do be a little they do
be a little longer we rolling already we
already
roll be a little long
I was so happy that there that's hilar
it is hilarious I remember like years
ago there was a girl I used to talk to
and she used to talk about she don't she
doesn't like uh loose balls she likes
them super tight yeah yeah and I had
tight balls at the time and then as you
get older and it gets hotter them thing
starts to droop a little bit and they
get a little depressed they just got to
start slipping out yeah here's the thing
if your balls ain't that if your balls
ain't too long by mid 30 40 then that
means you ain't got enough wisdom
you you haven't done enough your life
that's how base people's intelligence
let tell to drop their [__] pants hey
drop your pants brother no your ball's
Too Short brother you ain't you ain't
been long balls slipping out it means
you wearing boxers
alone boxing brief man oh [__] that's a
hard intro oh yeah hard
Andro oh no countdown 543 21 what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
The Genius brain podcast I got my boys
Rome and cam from dorm tment we just had
a manual here last week and uh we're
just flipping people in and out with the
new studio makes it a lot easier for me
so I don't have to do [__] makes sense
and we got the guys here where we're
traveling all the time all the time this
is what I wanted to talk about on this
podcast I know like typically on these
podcasts when I used to do like an hour
and a half once two hours we would just
talk about everything yeah for sure but
now I'm trying to be a little more
professional in the sense that I got to
I have questions that I want to ask I
have ADHD so what happens and we'll talk
about balls and that'll go into
something else yeah balls to travel yeah
especially with us oh yeah yeah so we'll
never talk about the things that I'm
curious about but I wanted to before we
can get into that there's this video
that he posted like specifically Rome
posted of him getting sexually harassed
before we get into that you know we
always come with gifts come empty got
come with gift [__] yeah yeah yeah come
on you know through it yeah we always
got you always got to keep you hooked up
if you guys don't know these fellas here
these two young black mened man a
sunglass company called Shady Side Up
Man and I got to tell you this is
actually one of the things I really
really uh respect that you guys started
because I always tell like creators if
you if you're tired of doing brand deals
create something that your people want
yeah right and this is super [__]
important right and I love this [__] man
and as you know you're you're the
Catalyst for us starting this we had a
conversation with him he wanted us to
start black soap line yeah he raised his
profilers first then we started a black
shades line so Shad the name of the name
of the company was I
believe
so he racially profiled us into starting
a business
unbelievable he was like or y'all can do
some type of lotion or some sort we and
I was like what pair would fit him and I
I was like maybe that would fit him
funny thing was here's the reason why I
wanted you guys to start like black soap
and the reason why and look this this
can be absolutely for anybody anybody
yeah is that you know products that
people need a reup tend to make the most
uh profit right yeah most of the times
with like clothing like you have to be
on top of your stuff but if you have a
product that people really like like
pre-workout what people have to reup on
your because you a good product it's
very true that's very true we we've
learned a lot in the past we've been in
business three years so we've learned
we've learned a few things in in
business so and that's definitely one of
them um but yeah uh so now you can go
into your uh and also you guys can go uh
these those our shades are discounted uh
right now so you can go online and grab
those so there you go once again that's
Shady Side Up Shady Side up but let's go
back to you getting sexually harassed in
Japan all right there's like this thing
where when I watch like my friends
suffer it makes me laugh so hard dude
and cuz you're like I know he's not in
real danger so it's it's funny
absolutely so if you guys so when I was
a kid one of my favorite Disney
animation films is Sword in the Stone
and if you if you watch Sword in the
Stone there's this scene where this uh
fat female squirrel sexually harassing
says Merlin Y and she looked exactly
like the squirrel so I started cracking
the [__] up I'm like how is this even
possible because in Japan that's not
what they do people keep to them yeah
yeah at all at all and and when you sent
me the meme one I was like this [__]
but then two two I was like this is
hilarious cuz it's exactly let me set it
up we're going downstairs to go to
dinner so we're with a group of people
uh but at the time it was only maybe
three people downstairs me and cam come
downstairs we waiting we just chilling
this this young woman comes up to me and
starts speaking Japanese at first
immediately I'm thinking oh she thinks
we're part of her group she she probably
with a group of people so she's probably
lost so we're like oh uh you know she's
speaking looking at me pointing me I'm
like oh no not me ke it real casual not
me bye yeah she keeps talking so I'm
like okay maybe so I'm trying to
understand what she's saying cuz she's
like pointing at me and like like woo
and very excited so I'm like uh I'm not
sure what she want but then she starts
touching me that was the weird part then
she starts I'm like who what's going on
and and it's funny because you know how
you're looking at somebody like help me
I'm looking at the security guy there
I'm like oh who was the guy in the video
uh which one oh Asian dude it was the
Asian dude the first one was the coner
the last one was a security guard but I
did what everyone else does these days
to I started filming I was like this is
hilarious that is what does these help
yeah yeah that's how you help these pull
out your phone and say somebody call
somebody
yeah was fing that was this this is
hilarious I'm like he's not in Danger
real danger funny so I like I got to get
this cuz he going to give you every
facial expression I was like in that day
I was like do I feel like bringing this
camera yeah I was like I'm just gonna
grab it just in casee thank God I just
grabbed it and so she's just going at it
bro and she is popping off Japanese like
like I'm fluent in it [__] I don't know
what you are saying to me so I'm looking
at conier so we calmly was like hey
could you like you know you see what the
[__] going on like handle it so he kind
of laughs he's like oh she says you are
cool I said all right he like stop it
like cool she goes away all right cool
let's get ready we still waiting to go
to dinner that's when I ask like
obviously she was blind if she thought
you were cool so she's a harasser and
blind that's maybe Mak I'm like no no
she seen clearly that had like no let
her cut you she's handicapped yeah yeah
she thought you were brille she thought
you were
BR like any bump stop for this week I
could tell you was breaking out that day
thought it was BR we sitting there I'm
like all right it's over bro she comes
full speed back over there grabs me from
behind and [__] I'm like yo hey yo yo yo
now I'm like like all right all right
and I can't here's the thing I'm a black
man in Asia I ain't trying to like shove
this woman and somebody be like he's
hurting women I can't go to Japanese
jail absolutely not not happening you
will have great food great food solid
food but I can't go in there so yeah
we're just like yo yo but it it's
getting uncontrollable now so now we're
like security like yo tell her so he
comes over there says something in her
ear and she
goes and and then stops and I was like
what what is going on so I have a
Japanese friend that was there so I sent
her to video like can you tell me what
she was saying and she said the lady was
saying you know who I am stop acting
like this so she probably thought wrong
with somebody else she like and she told
the the security guard or somebody like
he can speak Japanese he's plain oh my
God so she really thought he was some we
believe that some black man came here
and put that thing on 100% put that
thing on that's what I was wondering
it's like hey may bro you could just say
if you know like don't [__] lie to
the camera if out before let us know
like in my mind what it looked like it's
like you guys [__] before and so what
I was thinking is like yo this mother
got his dick but ja and they got a red
light district out there they yeah give
her that melon pan that melon
pan that melon pan you know and I was
just like I was like oh it kind of makes
sense now she probably hurt and like
come on man don't like that you know who
I am but it it was crazy man especially
because that was our third place in
Japan I mean in Asia and that was the
first time anything like that and I was
hoping that she would come back
throughout the trip like I was just
always ready to come back to the hotel
she's there again
here I like that would be great [__]
put an air tag on you and gave it to her
every time we came in the lobby I was
ready like I had a gun but it was just a
camera waiting for crazy man like if you
guys have never been to like Japan right
Japanese people are pretty much to
themselves very respectful of your space
there's not a lot of loud talking in the
Subways you stay quiet it's just a
really culturally and socially
respectful country so to see that was so
[__] it threw it threw us all it I I
was like and our some of the group
members that were with us was like well
maybe she just thought you were famous I
was like no if if it was different than
that it was different energy than just
you just famous [__] like yeah knows
Hey listen come on man you done you done
you done dipped in myushi roll I mean
you know you put your chopsticks on me
what's funny about that is I watched
your whole video with you and your wife
talking about Japan before we went I
need more I'm watching everything and
you said about don't talk loud I paused
it I said
wrong when D said wrong when we get to
Japan you got you got to take it down
Carri your voice projects like you going
to get us in trouble out here listen so
be mindful that happened to me too
because I'm [__] loud as [__] too so
we're just walking in like this
beautiful Park and I'm just explaining
something about look some she goes what
the [__] like like look around you it's
peaceful like read the room I'm like
disturbing all the creatures in the
Japanese Forest it's so I don't realize
how loud I am until I'm in that country
yeah no it's like it's quiet they not
they don't play none of that it just so
respectful like just you know getting on
the escalator everybody stands to the
left and all this I'm just like America
could never yeah could never thing like
we don't we don't have this idea and I
always said this too like uh Mariel's
friends who are from Japan will ask is
like how come America just can't do this
like because America doesn't have this
idea of what an American is so true we
all have a different perception of that
right we're a country full of just a
Melting Pot of everything so everybody
has their cultures and their language
and they come here and this is what
America is Japan is like a homogeneous
area like majority of people are
Japanese and it's old history it's
culture old ass history everybody else
and every like America's new yeah you
know what I'm saying so when people go
to like Japan or they go they have like
a certain sense of nationality so when
they think when people come here they go
oh we need you need to assimilate to us
cuz this is Japan so there's no ex
you're not an exception to the rule
right and a lot of people say this too
like in Japan um people who live there
like no matter how long you even live in
Japan you could speak the language
you'll never be Japanese like that's how
they kind of treat you I mean the big
thing it's funny cuz it don't feel like
that like everyone was so nice even the
places you said like Osaka and Kyoto
would be nicer Tokyo every cool like
yeah once you start going to Japan and
then you kind of we also don't live
there I guess and like you know the
language a little bit too most people
100% of the time can't tell
microaggressions cuz their
microaggressions is the nicest [__] ever
what I'm saying you like oh that's nice
so once I started going there three or
four times I was like oh you don't
[__] like me you know like most
people wouldn't be able to tell but like
there's like a little stank on it right
like their customer service isn't that
on point but compared to a lot of
American customer service it's just way
better so who the [__] so how do you
think they felt about if they watched
the video of the lady how do you think
they would have felt about her they
probably thought you guys were
[__] they was like what
this he didn't pay her he owes her
[__] money you can't just get your
dick suck and just leave back to the
States yeah she's like no he knows me he
no they don't like tips there but other
type of tips they may take yeah yeah
isn't the [__] non- tipping culture
the best thing that's the best no
pressure on you no PR pressure and if
you even try to tip they are a offended
like don't don't give me that money I'm
like man that's great it's sweet too the
Rick Shaw dude what he told you when he
to Tri man I was so we you we did the
little Rick Shaw and then at the end I
mean CU we on this back for 45 minutes
keep going around time and I'm like bro
I'm like I know y'all don't accept tips
yeah can I just can I just give you like
just just little something he's like no
no no your tip is the joy in your heart
wow I said come on you nice ass I got to
give you a bigger tip I want to give you
more
and he said you you know how you can tip
just tell people about my culture tell
them to come here and see my culture
damn dude like damn you guys you guys
America would never absolutely could
never another thing cordial like very
time I was waiting on a bus I just
missed the 11:00 I looked at the
schedule said 11:20 the next one at
11:20 I turn it's coming around the
corner right there right there every
train was on time I'm like I love that
shout out to our guy Yumi uh she she was
matter of fact we were going to uh do
the cart racing in Japan we on headed
there we didn't we weren't necessarily
late we actually early but we didn't get
there the time she wanted to get she
wanted to get there a little bit earlier
than that so we had cuz we had to pull
over find dire something we got on our
way she said it's only 5 minutes away
guys she was like I just want to
apologize for my incompetence I said God
damn it and I told everyone since then
that's the only way I'm sing apologize
you're you're late if you say I'm sorry
for my incon you know after you guys let
she killed
herself she took a [__] swach oh man
got on two knees I'm so no yeah no it it
was it was great I mean all of Asia like
we we've been in Bali we've been in
Thailand like it's been when we were in
Japan too we did like this uh one time
we did a touristy thing it was when I
was for the matcha company when we go
check out our farms and so this lady was
apologizing to us because the weather
was bad like you can't
you not Storm from XMen what do you want
she's like I'm so sorry the weather does
not perit I'm so sorry I was like it's
okay the whole [__] ride just kept
apologizing I'm like I don't know what's
going to change here like you you don't
have to apologize but she felt so bad
one of the Our God our God apologize too
cuz we were what part of town was that
yes I know he was in toky I just don't
know it's called was it akar Akihabara
that's where we were and our guy was
like oh this is an anime store you want
y'all can go in there so we like all
right I'm filming Rome going there and
we go downstairs and the more we get
into I'm like it's anime but it's porn
anime porn so I'm like I'm talking about
I'm talking about
everywhere floor floor we was like all
right let's go to the next floor maybe
something up there then it turns to
regular porn yeah then I go to the next
floor it's more it's this it's just five
stories of porn and people in there
buying porn listen when I see two young
black men I know what you guys
want squeaky ass Japanese
porn so then we leave and we come out
and we tell her she like oh my and she
just apologized for the rest of the
night was regular we were laughing her
because she like she was like she was
like why would they just have that on
the
street I like it's 14 million people
everybody is is not together you like
it's what she was like oh I so sorry our
night is ruin like no it's not ruined no
you actually made it better it's good
night like come to America we have the
same issue oh yeah absolutely it's
pouring everywhere don't even worry
about it [__] funny manaba is like uh
it's super popping right so it's like
kind of you know Beverly Hills like
there's a bunch of shopping places and
stuff like that did you guys ever have
any trouble finding clothes that will
fit you no no I did a unique this this
from the unique out there like it just
everything first off they got a 10 story
uniel why is it so many floors you went
to the biggest I went to the big yeah I
went to the big long H I was like this
is crazy they have a so if you guys are
are in Japan and you guys like Uno Uno
is dope it's like fashion Basics right
you guys go in there whatever unial
you've experienced here I think the
biggest one in the United States is in
Hawaii I'm not sure about that 100% but
picture that times 10 yeah that [__]
that shit's huge escalators they go
escalate I'm like oh this is crazy I'm
standard size so I never have issues
well they when I went last time I saw
that their shirt sizes are a little
bigger now so when I went there for the
first time like 10 years ago it's a
little different everything fit on me
like straight up cellophane WAP like
that [__] I was squeezed into an XL that
[__] was stopped at my nipples
and I was just like I just ruined this
shirt I have to buy it you know like
we're pretty much done here but I was
doing more thrifting though like
thrifting out there is
INS I'm so glad talk about this the most
organized thrift store ever oh yeah
color
C they solid when I saw that I went in I
didn't know it was a thrift store cuz
yeah we didn't either one we the only
reason I knew was cuz a smell I was like
is this a thrift store it smells like a
thrift store yeah Thrift got that smell
but colorcoded everything so anybody who
loves thrifting for clothes you got to
do it in Thrift or smell is like that
underarm smell you know it when you you
like oh that's yeah I know that would
the sad reminds me with my childhood
that's thing when I was a kid we used to
never we were so broke we couldn't buy
like new clothes so there was a my
parents store was right here was Chinese
restaurant to the of it and to the right
was a thrift store and that's where we
get all of our clothes so when I smell
it it reminds me of my childhood which
is so wild because people now will
Thrift I almost wasn't cool back then
almost can't do it cuz I'm traumatized
that's all I would get yeah not in Japan
though you do it in Japan yeah they got
fits and I'll tell you what that's the
most fashionable women I've ever seen in
my life like Japan the women are fly of
course you got the standard dress but
the ones that's like and I would try to
compliment them and you know they're so
shy I'd be like oh you're so FL and just
walk off did I offend her what you think
well like in Asian culture too you never
say uh thank you or you're welcome when
somebody compliments you they say oh you
look good they tell you no because
you're supposed to show how you're
humble and the humility so if you say oh
thank you it's like this
[__] the [__] who the [__] you think
you are so my wife when she lived in
Japan that's why she could speak read
and WR
when they said her host family gave her
compliment she said thank you they're
like okay hold on you don't do that you
say you say no and then you you you
basically tell them I'm not that because
you want to show humility but you're
still accepting the compliment so flip
side of that she comes to the states
right when she's a kid yeah uh this
happens in Korea too same thing her uh
English teacher her American teacher was
giving her a compliment and she goes no
I'm not and then she got in trouble
she's like when an adult says uh
compliments you you say thank you that's
very rude so she was so confused she
what the [__] am I supposed to do here
it's culturally so [__] different
speaking of Korea though since you said
that we had a layover in Korea was it
was it on it wasn't this trip it was
going to Bali Bali we had a layover in
Korea that airport is phenomenal airport
is phenomenal robots in there yeah
robots and [__] yeah that that [__] was
cool but one thing I knows about Koreans
there no butts in there it was no butts
in there it was no butts I had the
fattest ass in there
I was like David you would have been
thinking what's going
on they know I'm American when I walk
by right there oh yeah got some ass on
it right there you know what's weird
like Korea has been now moving towards
accepting like thicker bodies right okay
so before I mean I mean I I think it was
in the states too people are all about
that thigh gap when a girl walks see no
thigh touching which was always the
weirdest thing cuz it's not a very
American
or for us anyways right and so in
Korea there's I mean there is a lot of
fat shaming right so if you walk around
in your thicker they always say
something like the biggest compliment in
Korean is you have a very small face
like you are considered very pretty in
Korea cuz you had a tiny ass [__]
face big head like the bigger like
Korean people have [__] gigantic
heads too like it's just our thing I
don't know why but we have [__] huge
heads so when they see a small head
that's why gentle monster did with with
the with the shades yeah I understand
yeah so when they see that their the
their idea of beauty usually is like
somebody who's like really slender so I
remember back in the day like they would
make fun of you if you had a big butt
they'll call you like OD thingy which
means like Duck Butt Duck Butt but then
you know in America that's very coveted
oh yeah you need you need that duck butt
out here you need a little [__] duck
boot a little duck on you did you ever
notice to like in Kore when you were in
the airport there's nobody dressed bum
genius brain listeners well did you know
cold turkey might be great on a sandwich
but there's a way better way to break
your bad habits we're not talking about
some weird mind voodoo from that crazy
neighbor that Just Pets their cat with
their own tongue and that's how they
clean it that lady's weird and she
stinks we're talking about our sponsor
fume and they look at the problem in a
different way not everything in a bad
habit is wrong so instead of drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit fume is an
Innovative award-winning flavored air
device that does just that telling you
it feels great it's made out of wood it
has this clicky thing for people who are
fidgety and by by the way the flavored
air really tasty so for those people out
there who have something like an oral
fixation that you need to just put
something in your mouth that you need to
puff away at dude the fume thing is
pretty amazing I just have it in my car
whenever I'm bored cuz I fidget a lot
and it's pretty freaking awesome
stopping is something we all put off
because it's hard but switching to fume
is easy enjoyable and even fun fume has
served over 150,000 customers and has
thousands of success stories and there's
no reason that can't be you join fum and
accelerating Humanity breaker from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today head to tume.in use
code genius to save 10% off when you get
the journey pack today TR f.com and use
code genius to save an additional 10%
off your order
today genius brain farts this podcast is
brought to you by mood o my friends mood
is known for their federally legal THC
but now they're adding their most potent
prodct yet to the lineup introducing
hemp based thca flower the future of
legal THC and try it along with all of
mood's other amazing off offerings like
Delta eight flow gummies Vape cartridges
and a whole bunch more and for a limited
time mood is giving our listeners a free
gram of thca flour and 20% off your
first order that is freaking amazing
listen as a night cap my your boy over
here takes a little gummy maybe a little
bit of a pu puff and it helps me relax
and get into a good space because my
mind always races all the time and sleep
is super important for me and for me it
helps me with sleep and that's why I
love
mood products dude the best and like I
said the deal is amazing once 20% off
your first order and you get a free gram
of thca flour how insane is that try
mood's new thca flour today and for 20%
off your first order and a free gram of
THC flour go to
hello.com and use promo code genius
that's hello m o o d.com promo code Gus
for 20% off your order and a free gram
of thca flour today I didn't even really
pay ATT but I can see yeah I
don't shorts there's nobody they even
the girls when they go on the Plane full
makeup on you don't ever see them dress
like bum I don't like that was like the
weird thing so before I went to Korea my
wife told me you can't dress the way you
dress like you have to wear something
outside of just baset that's one way to
tell you that's what that's the first
time he knew that your wife thought you
dressed bu going to Kore like you have
to get the clothes that you have and you
have to wear
it I'm like can't just take a t-shirt
that's out the wrinkle closet and throw
it on I get it I get it cuz look I don't
at a certain point because you know like
got kickbox and I do the walks and stuff
dressing in clothes that look
appropriate is not is stopped Comfort
it's about age Comfort old I get look
what look what we have on sweats that's
mesh but even this would be way more
acceptable than what I normally dress in
I have like the I have the ashiest
clothes you've ever seen in your [__]
life like all my shirts that I wear on
the regular is not this deep it's like
this this is too deep of a black got you
okay you got all black that [__]
purple like David in here look like a
penny it's buty is caught up to the
times you know Kan did him a favor he
was than like damn your shirt's
distressed it's like n no no it's stress
it's
stress [__] sh smash my boxers it's
all hold up and [__] do they even got
one shirt that connect to his that was
funny yo that's his balls
slipping that's where it starts it don't
even go through the dick hole just throw
another one it just like cleans out no
she used to hate that [__] cuz I would
always have to ask her like okay where
are we going cuz depending on how I
should dress but then it just came to a
point now we've been together now almost
10 years so we're at that point now I'm
very very comfortable got which is so
funny because I do I I really love
[__] clothing like I buy clothes all
the time it's just more like I keep it
in the corner where yeah just just in
case just in case so every now and then
like if I do wear clothes outside of
just basketball shorts the [__]
Adidas slippers and the [__] high
socks it's it's usually laundry day cuz
my laundry days are flipped so if I have
to do laundry I'm wearing something
better if I'm not I'm usually wearing
the bum [__] cuz I just don't care
anymore so we know if I ever see you
dress up like oh it must have been
laundry 100% must been laundry day this
is actually laundry day today too the
funny thing is in the airport in in
Korea remember we had to listen so hard
to the announcements because the English
was so soft and I we what she say we
looking at each other I'm like I think
it just mean we you you y'all would love
Korea yeah I I mean I definitely want
definely So Korea for I like both
countries right yeah um Korea is a
little more chaotic so in terms of they
have the same organization type of stuff
but I prefer Korea's NTI okay okay yeah
Korea's NTI is [__] wild so like if
you guys are down to have fun Korea is
the place to be are both y'all single
right now yeah all right like I'm not
much of a partyer but out in out in the
country I just want to experience
everything so in Korea too A lot of
people already kind of speak English too
got um it's not great but it's enough to
like communicate and all of our street
names there are also in English Okay
yeah so they they kind of geared the
country I mean I asked people in Korea
and so they kind of geared the country
towards tourism soes sense they they had
this idea of when people come to the
country they want them to have the best
time cuz they want them to say great
things about Korea so they they kind of
watch after you it's it's actually
pretty [__] dope yeah I've heard
great things about Korea if you go to
like kangnam kangnam is like their
Beverly Hills M it's it's basically a
bunch of Americans there so when you're
there like half the people speak English
yeah yeah so food is [__] good too
delicious as hell like I it's hard to
say man like I I love both but obviously
I'm more partial to CB because I'm
Korean but Japan is just Japan is always
just a good place to It's Like A vibe
yeah definitely got to go back a certain
place place you go you don't go back but
that's a place I got to go back and it's
impossible to do everything in week
definitely can't yeah yeah so like I was
saying on my podcast people like oh this
is the best place to get this like you
wouldn't
know there's too much enti too much it's
like New York but clean it's no trash
cans on the street like but it's clean
but then when we got here it's trash
cans everywhere and it's litter on the
street I was like this doesn't make
sense America so [__] backwards sense
what is going on and then the eating
like I remember it's like everyone's
slim like I seen one person that was
overweight and I was just looking at him
like not even judging him but it was I
wasn't used to seeing overweight
Japanese besides myfriend your girl
besides her and one like I was telling
this F probably had some snacks in his
pocket that's why she she was trying she
was hungry DG it was crazy all of Asia
that we've explored I mean I still I
still want to go to Vietnam I still want
to there so many other Vietnam's [__]
fun and [__] too I want to go to all
these places it's too much like once you
go out in the world he's like nah I
can't stop I gotta I gotta I got to
goere yeah I mean it's it's interesting
right like uh I feel when I was younger
I never wanted to travel right because I
don't know if it's like a fear I just
didn't care but then you start to become
a better person when you do travel
because you get to see how everybody
else lives I think the the biggest
problem that we have As Americans
everybody looks as we look at ourselves
as we are the Pinnacle of society like
this is how everybody should do things
but then you go somewhere else they
don't give a [__] about it yeah you
that's why we go against the grand on
everything everybody else goes by
Celsius we say [__] it let's go
everybody else goes uh uh kilometers
[__] it let's go miles exact say process
exactly America ain't [__] Asia changed
everything for me like my eating habits
the way like we've been studying you
know the whole um cians and the blue
zones and uh you guys read books and
[__] huh yeah yeah we wanted to go to
okanawa while we were there but we had
to come back we like all right you to
find out how to live a thousand years oh
oh
Isles live there dude it's crazy but you
realize how much better you feel when
you're not eating all this process eat
fresh fruits that's in seasoned and
everything so it was like I changed
everything when we was in Bali we were
at one of the rice farms and we were
having lunch there and I asked U no cam
cam had asked for uh passion fruit juice
and she was like oh hold on one moment
she was gone for like five minutes came
back and she was like okay I can get you
your juice we have a couple left on the
tree she went to go look to make she
wanted to be fresh off the was in the
back door oh yeah she was like okay we
got a few left I'm like it's 12 cents
then it's so affordable it's so
affordable I ain't never been that
affordable crazy when I was in Japan I
me and my wife we went to like the top
top restaurants and we spent barely
anything like I think one of our meals
uh it was one of my favorite meals is is
this dish called tendon and tendon is
basically a bunch of temper fried dishes
with this soy based sauce over like rice
right had freshwater eel shrimp
different Seafoods everything that [__]
was $7 and it was probably top five best
things I've ever eaten in my [__]
life you know meanwhile you come here
spend $25 you're like what the let me
tell the other day I went to a breakfast
burrito spot and I was like I'm trying
to save some money let me just you know
it's expensive out here I got this $7
burrito it tasted like a $7 burrito and
I had a $7 burrito [__] after I thought
I was gon to die I literally thought I
was gonna die and I'm pissed you know
what I'm saying you know how crazy we're
in Thailand in puket and you know how
like you put your car down for
incidentals when I was checking out mind
you the whole time I'm there I'm eating
I'm eating lunch at the at the hotel I
got two massages I had a floating
breakfast all type of stuff when I was
check breakfast Flo that's you made it
when that [__] comes cruising to you
like like the [__] I'm checking out um
I'm like all right what's my total gonna
be she was like oh $118 I said huh
that's it that's how much my massage
cost and same for me like we stayed in
two different hotels so I was in another
and it's a festar hotel I got the ocean
view I had room service at least twice a
day I'm talking about Lobster shrimp I'm
full fish passion fruit smoothies I
checked out it was like $100 for the
week C that's nuts week I don't
understand that at all I don't don't get
when we were in Bali and Thailand each
of us got 21 massages we start counting
cuz that's how many we start getting cuz
they're so they're so afford
[__] you got bones in your body
21 I can't back mush the most expensive
one I paid for I got a 30 minute massage
20 minute body scrub and then I had a
milk bath for like 10 minutes that came
with snack is a milk bath a milk bath
and it came with snacks and it was only
$40 they [__] prepped you like they
do Fried Chicken D about of mil and I
was chilling in there
was like what with pick juice on the
side like hey yo chill the [__] oh man
no it's like the prices are insane I was
like I don't understand it like I and we
were at this hotel uh in this area
called Lina yeah in Bali North
Bali the best mage I ever had in my life
and and I I say ladies I understand why
y'all like booty rubs I get it that
woman hit the cuff of my cheek and I
said this is Sensational I said Thank
You Ma'am she was in there and they and
then I'm like I'm trying to give her
extra money and stuff like that she they
said thank you but then she was like she
was like anytime you come back you you
come back I said oh I'm coming back for
you yeah I'll be back for you I'm going
back the next day do they do you guys
get massaged when you're completely butt
naked or you still with your boxers they
have I still have my they they had
underwear on but they they get in there
they they roll up G if you go to like
any Asian one stuff they'll roll your
[__] underwear down and they'll go
right into your [__] ass which is
weirdest [__] hey one time I [__] you
[__] not dude I know this lady was
[__] playing because
I
don't because I I don't speak [__]
Mandarin or [__] jaanese but I know
giggling when I know this gig they're
like massaging my [__] right and I [__]
you [__] not this woman start
slapping my ass not even like a double
things where it feels like a massage I'm
talking about one of these B and I heard
her giggle I'm likeit is [__] making
fun of me with her friends and she's
over here making sweet Chinese buns with
my [__] booty so was other women in
there yeah and they were giggling I
don't understand what they're saying you
[__] Clapp my cheeks yeah you
slapping my ass and giggling hold on
brother slow it down that makes me have
you you been to poo cat yet no so you
ever heard about the ping pong show I
always want to know I wanted to
experience that all right so so you guys
want the one absolutely oh my God so all
right let me break it down so in puket
there's a road called bangler Road
bangler Road right yeah bang everything
is sex in Thailand bang it is this a
place a street of debauchery this thing
this is where all the nightclubs the
bars women danc on table
dispensaries all the Freelancers they
call them
in all that you like lady Freelancers I
love those videos as soon as you get
there ping pong show ping pong show like
soon as we stepped out the car they ping
pong show like we like yeah we going to
go but let let's just we just got here
let us get a lay of the land we just
landed yeah let me get a lay of the land
not a lay of the man out here let me get
a l of land so we going So eventually
look all right we walk the street cuz
it's not that long so then we come back
let's let's just get it out let's just
go so now you going in this back like I
would say like you know how NBA tunnel
looks like convention yeah it doesn't
look sketchy it look like that so we get
there we walk in it looks like a strip
club a bar women are topless so we look
at the stage as soon as we get there
there's a guy naked hard on with a
string attached to his penis and he's
pulling a lady that's in a cart behind
him with that so he's walking up so I'm
like this the first thing we I was like
all right so then he gets to the edge of
the stage everyone's just looking she
comes around with a drum I was like it's
only one thing that's about to happen he
takes a dick start beating the drun
beating it and so now I'm just like I'm
like this I'm looking at I don't want to
see this but then the beat start being
fired I'm like beat was kind of
fire really close to his dick like and
I'm just like I'm B My Head Start
freestyling you know I'm saying go off
then four like girls come up and they're
dancing I kid you not just like a Grand
Theft Auto stripper like they dead pan
it it's like what that's it for like 10
minutes so he was like they not even
getting naked they just so then they go
off another four come on same thing I'm
like all right then another four come on
they get topless we like all right so
then the show starts some more
entertainment this old lady comes
out she has darts no no one has a
whistle and the other one has a horn two
of them come out pull up they bend over
one puts the whistle in a vagina other
one puts the horn and they start pushing
you just
hear we all start laughing everyone
laughing in there like all right not
look good they start piecing it together
as [__]
grinding all you see
is so then so then like some more come
out then the old ladies come out out
again come out with darts balloons and a
straw a long Like Straw so it was like I
already know what's about they going
around anyone want to hold the balloon
absolutely not so they end up holding it
lady gets on the floor opens the leg
puts the straw in puts the darts the
lady holds up the balloon get the [__]
out of here she shoots accurate accurate
I'm like the dude on freaking what's
that what's that movie Lord of the Ring
The Arrow fck legist she didn't miss
once she hits six balloons in a row they
go off more strippers come on do a
little dancing but this is where it gets
wild those two old ladies come out again
like they the craziest come one a time
one comes out she just walks up we like
all right what's about to happen pulls
up her skirt no underwear we like
obviously she reaches in her vagina
pulls out a bird and we're like get the
[__] out of here bird she puts in it
Bird's not flustered bird chilling it's
chilling like it's been in there many
times this what this [__] got a
black he just chilling he don't fly away
chilling he just chilling and she just
looks at everyone everyone's like hey
that [__] was crazy I was so then she
walks off her partner comes up he was
like what's about to happen she walks up
pulls out her skirt like what is she
about to pull out of here she pulls out
a Geral jble and just flops it on the
thing and flops on the floor and the
Geral start moving a little bit and then
she pick get the [__] out this is where
Co started dude I don't give a [__] 100%
this is where Co started in those two
vaginas and this I lean over I said I
think maybe yeah I think time to go but
before we left they come around wanting
tips and she asked me for a tip I'm I'm
not tipping you for animal cruelty I'm
with Peter now I'm with them now I mean
well technically it was [__] on [__]
[__] on Geral so but it was crazy tip
here's a tip don't do that yeah no I was
like that have been through it and I
know that bird bragging to his friend
like yo I be in the [__] no you don't
no you don't yes I do watch come to my
show come to my show on
Friday they call me la
Larry I'll be in there it's nothing
vagina Virgil vagina Virgil Virg I
didn't know it was like oh no no and we
and and it's a list it's a long we was
only there for like 35 to 40 minutes if
we would have stayed ain't no telling
what we no ain't no telling I don't know
what's going on but I knew when people
told us to go that I ain't going to be
seeing no actual ping they got like a
donkey show they got allp I ain't with
the Beast of out what the [__] she got
the square [__] charge thing come out
a telling me your phone plug up your
your Tesla in there all type of [__]
like it was it don't
worry it was nut we seen one lady come
out she had two bottles one full of
water one empty poured the water in and
then start filling up the other bottle
how was that even possible how do you
even start this [__] that's what we said
we said when did you say come here Bird
yeah get in here just a couple of bird
SE in there just starts going
itself got to be yeast infection and
then security don't play ain't no
filming like if you were a girl and she
unzips her bag they coming over there H
with the light and trying to see what
she's grabbing for like you can't be
going there trying to do that's why you
never really see films that means 100%
that's even illegal in Thailand like
even in Thailand it's illegal like
you're not supposed to do this that [__]
that that road is like Vegas on steroids
man you guys ever go I I don't know if
you're interested in this but did you
ever get to see a mu Tha match out there
yeah we went front row in Bali though
not in
tile so my friends went on uh Thailand
he would like sometimes you get to see
young kids go perform but every now and
then if somebody drops out a fight
they'll just grab somebody from the
crowd who wants to fight I wish I would
yeah and so like he said that he saw
somebody go in from the crowd he goes
I'll [__] fight this guy he's like a
skinny dude and it was like you know a
thicker white dude that white dude got
kicked in the head in the first five
seconds and his tooth flew out right
into the [__]
crowd and then it was that was it genius
brain listeners thank you for the
support because this podcast is brought
to you by mmobile from billion ad
budgets and Arena naming rights to tens
of thousands of retail locations big
Wireless providers spend big to appear
like they're your only options how do
they afford it all that big Bill you get
every month mintmobile had a different
idea instead of brick-and morar overhead
Mt mobile is online only and what does
that mean for all of us a whole lot of
savings because Wireless plans for mint
mobile start at just $15 a month that's
unlimited talk text and data for just
$15 a month think of about all the stuff
that you could be doing with all those
savings you know groceries be expensive
you know the economy be going crazy
right now by boosting up our bills
everywhere that we go so if you could
save a penny here if we could save more
than just a penny with mmobile which is
dollars it'll help you out and that's
what I love about them to get your new
Wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com genius5
that's mintmobile.com
genius5 cut your wireless bill to 15
bucks a month at mintmobile.com
genius 15 my lovely genius brain farts
this podcast is brought to you by haries
I love me some haries my friends because
they have the best quality products at a
price that you'll love from the
legendary high quality razors to skin
products like exfoliating face wash and
Hydrating Lotion Harry's gives you a
premium shave without the premium price
tag get better quality and a better
price than other razors when you get
Harry's delivered right to your door a
smooth shave shouldn't be rough on your
wallet the starter set is a thir $13
value for just $3 at harry.com
genius it includes a five blade German
engineered razor weighted handle foaming
shave gel and a travel cover my friends
you don't want to miss out on this I've
been using Harry's for quite a while now
and I'll never go back the savings that
I get with the quality shave unbeaten
get your best shave ever with Harry's
razors and skincare products get a $13
starter set for just $3 at harry.com
genius that's harry.com genius for a $3
starter set today
I didn't know what to expect but then
when they started throwing them legs you
hear that [__] oh my bad it wasn't Bali
it was Thailand it was cuz it was
uh yeah where the full moon party is
that's where it was it wasn't Tha but we
we said front row and once they started
swinging we was like oh oh [__] you L
kicks connect oh yeah oh we saw knockout
we saw started off with two kids and it
kept going up we saw a guy we we knew we
seen the guy and he walked to the ring
and he had his wife and kid with him I
said damn usually when they got the wife
and kid with him it's not going to be
good yeah going be good my boy got in
there got that ass whooped no his wife
was waiting down there by the ring come
on left her ring right there yeah we're
good and he got whooped to like he was
limping he was he left he was like I was
like damn limping cuz you know them leg
kicks are vicious like mu Tha man like I
trained it for about like a year and you
just never get used to those kicks like
they just you just don't get used to it
there's no you do it can't even really
block like you just have to block it
with your other Shin so it's just it's
to deter the other person from throwing
them too much cuz both of you get hurt
but there's no like you check it and
then you're still cool it just hurts the
first time I got kicked super hard it
was on accident but the dude kicked me
and he's a pro mu TIE fighter he hit my
shin and it hurts so bad I just dropped
and then when I went home I was touching
my shin I was like oh there's a dent
like my [__] finger just went in I'm
like you [__] cracked my [__] and we
seen that's what happened to one of the
uh young younger boys he was uh he was
fighting fighting and then he got hit in
that Shin that boy say he was like I'm
down I can't I can't be fighting and
worrying about feet and I only can do
one which one we doing I can't worry
about all four that's why if you see
somebody getting a certain stance you
about to fight brother yeah you got it
you got it I'm not doing if he just do a
kick right quick then
get can't worry about four limbs dog
these these [__] Muay Tha people are
so insane like they Harden their Shins
It's like they call it the art of eight
limbs right you got your hands your you
got your hands your feet your your shins
and you also have your elbows they also
have a really good clinch game where
they just [__] snatch your [__]
neck and you can't do [__] right and
they're just tossing you on the floor
beating the [__] out of you and I think
like for me it's like I enjoyed it for a
hot second but then once you get to a
certain level it's like I'm I'm good
yeah you got to be a man to do that I I
I give you that like I'm going to do
these podcast got time for this [__] you
going to [__] talk [__] about
Fighters that's it you got worry about
feet on the podast yeah absolutely not
it just hurts so bad there's no there's
no it feels like electricity going
through your whole [__] body and
there's like another thing that people
will feel too is like if you guys have
ever been punched in your liver it's the
weirdest feeling ever like you get hit
and you get shocked and you're cool for
a second and then you just drop y it
shuts your whole [__] down I remember
the first time ever happened it wasn't
from a punch it was from a kick I got a
liver kick and then you know the dude's
like half my size but he just hit it
right perfect and I just stopped I was
like we're good and I
went I just fell the oh yeah them body
shots wear you out absolutely um but
what's also funny about Asia like I
always said I want to live out the
country for like a year but I never knew
how to answer for where Bali yeah yeah
wow B and we going to try if nothing
keeps us here we going to try to go for
six months next year
wow but you guys could do everything
online anyway yeah yeah that's we're
trying to move everything to that so
make it easier only thing that keep us
here is like of course if it's an
opportunity that makes sense we'll we'll
stay here but but if not then yeah we
want to go do that because just I mean
six months you're going to spend about
$46 anyway absolutely that's another
reason
like you got to understand like you
spending a hundred and something dollars
within a week is at the top of luxury
yeah that's whole time I'm there whole
time I'm there I'm like is my account
moving like I had to really look at like
did it move yeah yeah cuz once you take
even money out the ATM but we took I
took $300 of American to Bali just when
we first got there I didn't go to the
ATM until the third week I was there
that's crazy man that blows my [__]
mind that's crazy when I when I hear
about that [__] it's like what is it
really worth being here that's what you
say the whole time I put online before I
can said why am I coming back and
someone said your mom I said my mom
don't even live in the country anym she
moved out the country like so no why am
I coming back it's it's wild when I see
how much our dollar can stretch
elsewhere right and also too I feel like
people people elsewhere from what I've
seen they they kind of live very simple
yeah very simple you know like here it's
kind of a rat race like you're always
like comparing yourself to other people
out there I mean obviously you know I'm
making a general statement you know
everybody has like their own like social
issues and stuff like that but from an
outsider coming in like oh it's just a
little different out here you know let
me tell you something we were uh we were
in ubo in B so uh the first the first
part of the trip we were in more city um
the second part of the trip we it got a
little bit nature and we always know
like when it come nature you going to
have some you going to have some
creatures yep got to deal with nature
when you're in nature so our first hotel
beautiful hotel like the the the layout
is beautiful and so they had me and cam
in this Villa so the Villa is just by
itself top floor bottom floor it's
separated from the rest of everything
else but when where we at at the Villa
we see us a lot of field and a lot of
things so we was like oh it's some [__]
out here for sure yeah so we go to
dinner that night and we're used to
seeing the uh you know the small little
geckos SM but at dinner we seen one that
was a little bit big we it about that
big we was like you don't want that in
your room want that in your room you
like you might have to call somebody
come get that so you already kind of
paranoid a little bit and up to this
point it's been 3 weeks in Bali we've
been up in the mountains I have escaped
any type of cu cu when you wake up you
just pray you don't see nothing first
thing I do I just look but this is what
[__] us up about the Villa so they're
showing us to Villa in the bathroom
window is probably [__] the window kind
of big like that the window big entrance
long size of this these backdrops as
they can see so but here's the thing who
did this infrastructure this place
because the window don't have it just
got a a blind cloth it's no glass no
glass no nothing so it's open so you're
like [__] so I'm like worst case
scenario is mosquitoes yeah yeah yeah
but you just
hoping first off we kept those shits
closed just so it was hopefully scare
off but you in your mind you like every
time I go to the bathroom I'm be
thinking what the [__] is in here and
I'm more paranoid I'm on the bottom
floor where everything go start bottom
so we go to dinner everything cool we go
back in the room that night we look I
call him he was like you see anything I
was like no I ain't see nothing in my
bathroom like nothing M I kept that
bathroom door
and I put a towel under littleit I'm
like if something come in there they
going be able to get under so I just
kept it there good so the next morning
he calls me he says it [__] happened
the worst the worst thing [__] I said I
said it done happen it it improper it
and this how I knew it was serious he
was like no come down here so and it was
the Japanese
girl that would have been I scared then
yo I from my perspec so I wake up that
morning and go to the bathroom and every
time I use this bathroom I would open it
slowly just in case it's something
something in there I have time just to
you know right back so I'm opening it
I'm looking at the floor I don't see
nothing I look up I just close it I said
come on
man damn I open it back up I get the
camera now I'm filming huge gecko that
[__] black big I I got I got footage of
it too I'll show you black that [__] and
it's just on the wall like a burglar
like Spiderman he probably looking at C
I'm like the [__] this black dude
looking at me Fu going on you know me I
got to film it so I'm filming it so
people can see it and I'm like and then
I open it some more it wiggle and go up
like the I call the front desk like hey
y'all got to come get him they're like
get who
him so then it take like 15 minutes
buddy pull up he got a broom I want him
to come with a gun this Liz but he got
the broom he go in there he's like in
there he can't speak English I'm like
yeah like so he going there he's banging
on stuff banging on stuff we don't see
him so that's the wor now like [__] man
so then I got leave now we hosting the
group and everything so I leave they say
yeah we going to come back bring a
ladder and everything they came back I
never seen it again but that first day I
said ROM I got shower in your bathroom
I'm not brave enough for this I said
tomorrow be more Brave that [__] that
[__] was big buddy we'll we'll show you
first of all like I don't like it when
first okay if something is this big
that's that's the size SI that [__] was
big there's no way it should disappear
and then not show itself again that
doesn't make sense ridicul that's the
devil that's not supposed to happen cuz
how am I supposed to sleep I can't think
like what what we doing can I tell that
happens to me with spiders right I see a
spider that's the scariest one for me
that's what I was worried about I go
back I get the the paper towel I come
back it's gone my man gone how are you
[__] gone my walls are all white like
I you I should be able to see you now
you want me to sleep but I can't [__]
sleep [__] this size where are
you and that's the thing with like
Australia they got Australia crazy I
want to go but I can't go to Nature side
I'm not yeah if I go to the nature side
I'm not spend the night I'm just going
to go we look though you guys might have
to risk it because I would say this out
of all the places that I've been to I
think Australia has some of the baddest
women I've ever seen in my oh Australia
has some yeah they they I don't know
what's in the water over there yeah yeah
yeah yeah they they do got some things
over they also have very thick white
women yeah dude the Asian women too it's
weird press press look how big this [__]
is we might have to send you this clip
to put in the Pod oh
100% that [__] is oh hell no that's not
even dog that's a Japanese demon dude
that's called a that in Bali that was in
Bali I don't give a [__] it it came with
you it no that's that's too big that's
too that's that's crazy that's way too
big that's crazy you got to see when it
moves it's going to move watch how it
Wiggles off this [__] make my long
balls watch how it Wiggles off balls bit
come on
play oh it just froze because the phone
scared too oh it Ain play oh is this the
is this the photo is this a photo this
is the photo is it no it might have
froze it might froze got the mole
hand got the mo hand I watch that video
every now and then in case I want to
just laugh yeah we'll send it to you but
that [__] was so bro that that like too
many like you and you just paranoid but
overall we didn't see too much that was
the craziest one we seen that why do
that [__] look like literally a black
hole Yeah darkest lizard I've ever seen
in my [__] life dude and look I don't
have an issue with it outside my room
come inside my room that's when it's
like it's like who who makes these rooms
why would you not put no type of glass
like racist white people you stay
outside the house like I got no problem
with black things what you come inside
my house
price I understand racism
like I get these white people I spoke my
name with a K when I saw
that oh man that's funny man it's like
damn this just all started to click it
makes sense yeah yeah no but all the
travels been beautiful everywhere you've
been has been it's been it's been
amazing oh my God monkey rob a dude at
Monkey Forest they told him don't bring
you have your stuff out that monkey was
in that pocket boys and come up out of
get that I'll tell you this man I wish
we could we're going to do a second
podcast after this we'll wrap this up I
want you guys to plug in the travel
stuff that you're doing too okay right
specifically because I think it's such a
good introduction for people to travel
with the group of people who are ready
to have fun and our groups are chill
like super chill yeah if you guys ever
want to travel and you're like okay I
want to travel with people that are
having fun you have to be very selective
because one bad [__] seat can ruin
your whole [__] trip and those
[__] need to die it's like we
spent money we spent time and you're
going to why would you bring any of that
over here don't even make sense the
beautiful thing though everyone has
matched our energy I feel like we
attract the same people that's like us
so every trip has been phenomenal
everybody's down to do stuff trying new
things if you don't like it that's cool
I would say so our next one is Brazil in
May and so if you guys want to go with
us we'll put the link here like honestly
you can reserve your spot now uh it's
20% down and then you pay the rest at
least 90 days out so maybe like they
have payment PL February yeah they had
pay
you can whatever but I would advise you
we we keep a nice tight group of people
like people from our first B Trip are
are coming they came to Japan and now
they coming to Brazil like they love it
like and we still keep in contact with
everybody everybody's super cool like
you you'll Vibe with us if if you come I
think I think it'll be an experience I'm
going to leave that in the in the video
link and also in the video as well if
you guys want to sign up for that uh
plug all your guys' socials yeah um well
uh I am i r aot i r oom
a lot um of course you got Shady Side Up
the Shady Side Up and uh if you want to
yeah we got dorm tment ComEd tra we have
to put all the all the links I'll put it
all in there we we got all the things
cam from DT with a c not a k only when
that's lizard
around a lizard there
3 camera oh
yeah get that black thing
out I had a hood on when he showed
you're not
welcome get pillow case like what are
you doing with this pillow on your hand
what's going on yeah you must be lost he
said get that liger out of
here get that Li that's funny that's
funny oh
man all right y spring every Sundays at
12 p.m we'll see y'all next time peace
keep your balls in my lovely genius
brain farts this podcast is brought to
you by Harry no matter why you shave
hares as you cover for the best shave of
your life at a price you'll love get
better quality and a better price than
other razors when you get haries
delivered right to your door Harry's
makes the skincare products that will
give you the best shave ever creams
washes and lotions that will keep your
skin healthy and hydrated my friends get
your best shave ever with Harry's razors
and skincare products get a $13 starter
set for just $3 at harry.com genius
that's harry.com genius for a $3 starter
set today